chess online is booming in only a couple of
weeks hikaru and magnus will be competing in
the chess.com speed chess championships which one
of those fighters is going to take the top prize
over a hundred thousand dollars in prize money in
this video we're going to take a look at hikaru's
previous top five tactical moments from chess.com
competitions make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel we're going to start off
with a nice and easy one i like gradually getting
you into the action like a lovely little curve
up hill or downhill whichever way you're going
here we see hikaru with the black pieces placing
against the woman's top champion ho yifang
now this is a pattern i'm sure a
lot of you are familiar with but
what move now forced ho yifang to resign and
what is the correct checkmating sequence here
i'm doing the eyebrow pay attention i don't think
i have eyebrows being ginger but you get the idea
knight 2f2 check and this is the start of one of
the most beautiful checkmates the smothered mate
we're gonna smother that white king in pain
with our queen and knight combining beautifully
together there's only one move king to g1 and
now knight to h3 double check and at this moment
well obviously ho yifan could see what
coming so she had already resigned
if the king goes to f1 that is checkmate
what i call the kiss of death checkmate
and the other way the king could go in my eyes
is even more pretty and that is with the king
going into the corner where it will be trapped as
after queen to g1 oh yeah man whatever captures
that queen let's say the rook the knight slides
into this square and the white king is entombed
to this checkmate beautiful stuff well poor old ho
yifang features twice in my examples here nothing
against you fang you're a fantastic player love
the way you play unfortunately hikaru's just got
some beautiful finishes against you now this
position a little bit harder than the last one
how did white force check mate here in a very nice
pattern again maybe not too hard we're keeping it
a little bit easy today so everyone can have a
little go at the checkmates can you see it well
first of all rook takes g7 check yeah that's easy
i'm sure you saw that one two rooks on the seventh
rank is a very powerful combination it's like
having a double barrelled shotgun not a single
one a double barrel one king two h8 and what is
the key move here the key move is now rook 2h7
check and this is a very pretty way to finish the
game if the king goes to g8 then rook g7 is mate
and if the knight captures the rook well
there's a number of ways to check mate here
i'm only going to demonstrate one can you see
the other ways knight to f7 double check it's
that queen and knight combining so well together
again and after king to this square what checkmate
you want to play i always like checkmating
with the knight because the knights one of
my favorite pieces knight takes h6 checkmate a
demonstration of the power of the two rooks and
the queen of knight well hikaru and magnus have
faced off against each other on numerous occasions
and this is one encounter from the chess.com
chess.com competition hikaru with the white pieces
now plays a move which looks very illogical maybe
this is not such a stunning individual move by the
looks of it but it really is beautiful d4 and
this looks so weird because you're blocking in
your prize piece your bishop on c3 but it's what
happens next which is the idea behind this hikaru
is trying to release the other bishop if both
of those guys get in the game it's going to be
completely hopeless for magnus who has the black
pieces magnus tries bishop to d8 and here is the
idea d5 that pawn has to be captured and now
queen to e5 and you can see this little pawn
advance has really demonstrated the power of the
two bishops d4 was tried the bishop slides in
and after king f7 bishop takes d4 and black's
position is hopeless the queen is aiming to come
into a square like g7 and these bishops just
dominate everything a very nice win for hikaru
over magnus magnus has had his fair share of
wins who's going to win in a couple of weeks time
do place your bets below hikaru seems to be faring
very well recently at top level but he's got to
keep it up against well the world champion of
course you may have noticed there's a bit of
a theme in the tactics that i have picked today
and in this one we see wesley sew with the white
pieces playing against hikaru and now it's hikaru
to move and to force a deadly attack i have to say
it's a funky night and queen day today
what did hikaru do can you see the winning
idea well he now plays rook takes b4 and this is
the move to clear up that diagonal for the queen
and use his two knights and queen to weave
a checkmate net against wesley's king
this has to be captured the queen now gets on the
important diagonal with a major check and really
here white has no defense wesley tried king to h1
had the queen been met this check by king to f1
well i think a move such as knight to h5
would be good enough that knight comes into g3
but after king to h1 the next move is the
important one again knight coming to this square
is good but there's an even more forcing move and
that is oh yeah knight takes e4 it's always nice
to play a capture rather than a silent move the
knight again is threatening to come into g3 with
checkmate there's no good way to stop this move
and after queen takes e4 knight to f2 won wesley
so and the game as well knight and queen power in
action well the last example comes about in the
ending a lot of people may get a bit complacent
in the last part of the game thinking how it's an
ending boring i'm gonna go and have a little nap
wake me up when it's a draw but in actual fact the
ending can often result in crazy tactics
yet again ho yifang is on the receiving
end of some naka magic here but what move now
allowed hikaru to create a deadly breakthrough
g5 this is a beautiful way to create a pass pawn
on the h file this is stage one of the tactical
sequence now ho yifang took that pawn otherwise
hikaru would have just gone g takes h6 and now
the point is h6 getting near to queening the black
king has to try and stop that and what is part two
of the tactic part two is b6 a lovely two-sided
combination here now the b pawn is threatening to
storm down the board and ho yifang had to give
up her bishop but after bishop takes d6 it's a
hopeless situation the h pawn is still too strong
hikaru has that extra piece lovely lovely tactical
vision there be by hikaru it's going to be very
interesting to see how he faces off against magnus
what do you guys think do leave your comments
below in the chat is hikaru gonna take the first
prize and be the 2020 chess.com speed chess
champion i don't know it's going to be close
i'm looking forward to watching so we have some
crisp and nice tactics there from hikaru who is
deadly online he seems to be getting better and
better just look at his results in the chess.com
titled tuesday event i don't know if he's going
to be able to get through magnus but i'm going
to be watching it as i'm sure most of you guys
are as well remember like this video subscribe
to the channel and we're going to be watching
some of magnus's most amazing news very soon